la sncf pourrait fermer une vingtaine de
gares au 1er janvier 2021 sur la ligne j
reliant la gare de saint-lazare à
l'ouest parisien l'une informations
avancées par la cgt cheminots de menté
vexin en cause un nouveau projet de la
sncf
baptisé trajectoire gare
ce projet trajectoire gare va supprimer
supprimer 20 gars à deux ouvertures de
guichet ces gars qui sont nommés à être
fermé on restait ouverte bien sûr en
tant que garde mais les guichets seront
fermement les usagers n'auront plus
accès à l'achat de billets ou de
renseignement ou d'informations ou ce
que tout usager a à droit d'obtenir
quand il vient dans une gare les gares
concernées seront situés entre conflans
sainte honorine et gisors ainsi que
celle entre conflans sainte honorine et
mantes la jolie autre point qui inquiète
le syndicat cheminot
l'accessibilité pour les usagers ainsi
que leur sécurité à ce point de vue là
il ya le point de vue des personnes à
mobilité réduite des toutes sortes qui
ont à toutes sortes de handicaps
les personnes âgées qui sont pas
toujours tous férus d'informatique ou
enfin comme pour reprendre la parole
d'un élu tout le monde ne rentre pas
dans les cases et en cas de situations
perturbées le jour où il ya enfin quitte
messieurs on le sait les trains qui
tombent en panne il se passe quelque
chose un accident de personne n'importe
quoi qui peut se passer le train est
arrêté en gare les gens seront livrés en
gare à personne
pour les syndicats ce projet pourrait
engendrer la suppression de 95 postes
contacté la sncf n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos sollicitations